what I like about this you see the fact
that the culture the patriarchy God the
Father will say here is holding the
suffering individual in his arms and
that's encapsulated by nature it's it's
very much like the story in Pinocchio
where Geppetto Pinocchio wasn't able to
go down into the depth and confront the
terrible monster at the bottom of being
without having support from his father
even though his father ended up trapped
inside the whale if he wouldn't have
been supported to begin with he wouldn't
have been able to do it and you know
I've really seen this and I really seen
this in people it's a hell of a thing
not to have the confidence of your
father it's really really hard on people
you know if your father is someone who
says to you you can do it I really
believe that you can do it I'll support
you in what you're doing I think that
you can sort it out and then acts
towards you in that way that's a gift
that really almost no one else can
provide you with mothers obviously
provide I think they provide the same
kind of gift but earlier you know
because the mother has to take care of
the infant when the infant is just
completely dependent and so a NEFAs
Erickson's idea to erik erikson as the
mother is is the person who establishes
the relationship that allows the
developing person to manifest trust
realtruck while you're being carried for
crying out loud you know you can be
dropped and the mother is also the
source of food but the father seems to
be something like the and I'm being I'm
obviously parsing these things farther
apart than they can be need to be
because the father can play a nurturing
role and the mother can play an
encouraging role but we'll keep it
simple for now the father seems to be
the thing that supports and encourages
and says well yeah you know your little
as small and all of that and you're
subject to destruction and and and
bullying and social pressure and all
that but I know you can do it I know you
can do it and there's a force in that
that's unbelievable and people who don't
have that have a have a hell of a time
it's actually one of the things that's
quite fun about doing psychotherapy
because you get people who have damaged
farther figures harder with the damaged
mother figure a because it's so bloody
deep you know I had a quiet who I just I
just thought she was a remarkable person
but her relationship with her mother was
really disruptive it was really really
hard to she says she would she told me
it was like
had been torn out of her at an early age
that couldn't be replaced it's read if
you just can't be someone's mother you
know it's really hard you're just not
there enough for that but you can sort
of be someone's surrogate father that's
a that's a role you can play later and
that's what educators do at least to
some degree although now they're trying
to be mothers and providing safe spaces
and all of that which is not really all
that appropriate so that so the father
is an encouraging figure and allows the
individual at least in principle to
support the catastrophe of being
voluntarily and so anyway so those you
know those images are just you're
brilliant beyond belief absolutely
brilliant beyond belief